hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear this is our monster march theme
this uh month so what i've been trying
to do i don't know if you guys have
noticed but um doing the theme for the
months that's kind of like a new thing
but what i've tried to do not always
like sometimes it doesn't work out like
this but i post two of these a week so
earlier in the week like on thursdays i
try to do like a newer film as in like a
21st century uh you know and then on
saturdays i try to do like an old one
usually like from 60s 70s 80s something
like that so because i like to kind of
have old and new you know how i do
but yeah so we're doing monster march
monster march this month
and here was a movie that uh i had been
wanting to see for a while because it's
amicus this was actually the last amicus
film that they made before the studio
folded uh and it's not an anthology i
think i'm gonna do anthologies for april
now that i'm thinking about although we
reviewed a lot of anthologies but
there's still a shits on out there that
we haven't done yet so um so yeah i
might do that next month
but i want to do this one because it
just it was it's been on shutter for a
really long time and it just keeps
coming up and peter cushing is in it and
i was just kind of like okay well that
sounds like uh something i need to see
so we finally got around i finally got
around to watching this this is the
beast must die from 1974.
this movie is
okay i have to say how you feel about
this is gonna probably be predicated
upon how you feel about real gimmicky
kind of stuff i think this movie didn't
need to have the gimmick but honestly i
kind of like it i found it kind of
endearing it's uh the gimmick is very
william castle
which uh i'll get into a minute but yeah
so this came out in 1874. uh the
director of it was paul uh annette or
annette who i think as far as i'm aware
this is his only film credit i think he
normally did tv like eastenders and
grange hill and stuff like that so you
know soap opera type stuff on british tv
so i think he was mostly known for doing
that but um so i think this was the only
film that he ever uh directed and this
was actually based on a short story
called there shall be no darkness by
james blish
now what this is is essentially and this
and everybody that uh you know worked on
this film has said this so it was
actually
completely deliberate
it's essentially a horror take
on an agatha christie
story uh most specifically and then
there were none also known as ten little
indians
so it's a murder mystery like a parlor
mystery
except with a werewolf okay
so that's what we have going on now as i
said there's a lot of kind of like big
stars in this the main uh guy in it is
calvin lockhart who the whole time i'm
watching this movie i'm like god damn it
it's like who the [ __ ] i've seen that
dude and i turned out i went to his imdb
page he's been in a [ __ ] ton of stuff he
wasn't like so much stuff sort of like a
lot of blaxploitation stuff in the 60s
and 70s but i recognized him from
coming to america wild at heart and twin
peaks walk with me he was in those three
movies so i said okay well that must
have been where i've seen it before
because i've seen those a million times
uh but that's where any but he'd been at
a bunch of stuff prior to that as well
uh peter cushing in this as well
uh as i already mentioned charles gray
uh is in this who you know a lot boots
into bond films i know him as you know
the guy from rocky horror picture show
and a very young michael gambon is in
this as well which
i barely recognized him because
i was just i mean i've seen him in a
[ __ ] ton of stuff but i was used to
seeing him like as an older man and he's
fairly young in this so it took me a
second and i was just kind of like oh
yeah okay that's who that is
so what you have going on with this
there's a guy
calvin lockhart is the main character
and he plays this kind of
multi-millionaire
and super hunter named tom newcliffe
now i guess
this makes a little bit of an homage to
like most dangerous game because i think
it's and i think that was deliberate
like where they were trying to say oh
he's hunted every animal on earth
maybe including people i don't really
know they don't go into that but
one thing that he wants to hunt is a
werewolf
and he has determined
kind of somehow if they said in the
movie i don't remember if they said but
he's determined that a group of his like
among his group of acquaintances
one of those [ __ ] is a werewolf
and so he invites them all to his
palatial estate
to like during a full moon like three
days of the full moon to determine which
one it is so that he can kill it now at
the very beginning of the movie and this
i kind of want to get into this too
because i kind of feel like some people
said that this is maybe where
the werewolf gimmick uh maybe kind of
shoots the movie in the foot because
you know that one of these characters is
a werewolf like from the very very
beginning because literally the first
part of the movie and this was not the
director's idea by the way this was
actually the producers
that wanted to do this because like i
said amicus was kind of going on the
toilet at this point this was their last
film so they really wanted this movie to
make money
so
apparently they thought that a gimmick
would be the best way to do that so at
the very beginning of this movie it
basically says this is like a detective
story where you are the detective uh one
of these one of the guests at this you
know party or whatever is a werewolf can
you guess which one it is and then it
says at the beginning it says there'll
be a werewolf break after we've shown
you all the clues and you know you have
to guess who the werewolf is and indeed
like about 50ish minutes into the movie
there is a werewolf break that i think
is 30 seconds a minute something like
that and it's just like ticking did you
guess who the werewolf was is it this
person this person and uh you know so
there was that kind of whole thing but
one thing that i did think was
interesting was that if if it didn't
have that gimmick which i kind of like i
said like i said i thought it was kind
of endearing
but
i will argue that if you didn't have
that gimmick and if you didn't sell it
because they did kind of sell like the
beast must die the poster art you could
tell it was going to be like a werewolf
movie because it was like a full moon on
it with like kind of a werewolfy looking
head in the moon if they had sold this
more as a murder mystery and kind of
downplayed the werewolf thing i wonder
if that might have like marketed a
little bit better i'm just i don't know
i'm just i'm i'm blue sky in here
because i do kind of think the way that
it opens
is you have uh calvin lockhart's
character and it appears that he's being
pursued
through these woods by a bunch of dudes
like in helicopters like with [ __ ]
machine guns and [ __ ] like that and
they're all like chasing him
and then he keeps like falling down he's
like oh there's a camera in that tree
and there's a microphone like stuck down
here in the ground and all this other
stuff and you're just like what the [ __ ]
is going on is this guy the werewolf
what you know what i mean i thought we
were gonna like get a chance to figure
out who it was but it fi you find out
that
what he's actually doing all these dudes
that are chasing him they're not really
chasing him they're just he has set up
his
mansion and all the ground starting the
mansion as essentially they put like all
the they put cameras they put
microphones they put like motion sensors
they put all this [ __ ] around there
because when he invites the werewolf or
the party to his house whoever's the
werewolf he doesn't want them escaping
so he has like essentially established
this big like perimeter of technology
and he has like this one guy who's
watching all of it he's got all the tvs
and everything like that so that when
the werewolf like wolfs out they don't
escape so he and he has like all these
you know like dudes like helicopters and
[ __ ] like that like on retainer uh to
take out the werewolf in case he is not
able to spoiler alert doesn't work out
as well as he expected as things usually
don't in this type of situation
so uh so again you you kind of have you
have that happen and then
uh he he addresses his guests uh all of
whom are uh suspects in this whole
werewolf mystery that you're doing so
you have charles gray who's playing like
kind of a diplomat but
he got in trouble you know most of these
people have something
you know much like a murder mystery any
kind of murder mystery everybody around
you know every single person is like
sketch in some way so any one of them
could legitimately be the werewolf
you know most of their uh sketchiness
involves oh well you were in this one
town uh you know or every time you were
in this town like people would disappear
and turn up with their throats you know
torn out and [ __ ] like that which you
know that is a little suspicious i'll
give you that but uh yeah so that it's
mostly that kind of thing so yeah so
charles gray plays a diplomat then you
have a husband and wife named jan and
davina
and i guess jan was like a a piano like
a concert pianist like quite famous uh
and davina is his wife
and then you have a guy named
paul who
is an artist but he said that he started
out in medical school and as a supposed
prank like he and his fellow medical
students like decided they were gonna
like eat human flesh like they didn't
kill anybody they said but they were
just like yeah what the hell there's
there's a cadaver right there i mean you
know what i mean so uh so yeah so ever
like i said everybody has some like kind
of sketchy [ __ ] about them uh and then
peter cushing who is fantastic and
everything i kind of wish he was in this
a little bit more although he does get a
lot of screen time and he does get a lot
of uh of lines and stuff because he's
actually an archaeologist
and his specialty is werewolves like
lycanthropy
so he's kind of the one that provides a
lot of the exposition about werewolfery
and
interestingly and i guess like i said
they're trying to
make everybody seem like they could be
the werewolf so when he's talking about
werewolf ray like at dinner he's talking
about how werewolves are just like
victims you know what i mean because
they can't help it like they can't help
being a werewolf and like wolfing out
and killing their family or whatever
like whenever it's a full moon so i
think they were trying to make that it's
just like oh well he wants like sympathy
for the werewolf so obviously he must be
the werewolf but i never thought that he
was the werewolf because i was sitting
there thinking
would they really do that to peter
cushing like make him turn into a
werewolf i'm like i don't really think
they would but you know what i mean i
don't like
but yeah but so he does get a lot of
that kind of uh [ __ ] about it
so basically the rest of the movie is
like i said essentially like a parlor
mystery where they're trying to figure
out
which person is the werewolf now one
thing that i will say is that
one i kind of liked the angle where he
had all this technology like around
where the whole grounds were under
surveillance essentially but it ends up
not really
working out because at some point like
the werewolf which
that's another thing and i'm not going
to [ __ ] on them too hard for this uh
amicus because look they made some
fantastic movies they made some of my
favorite horror anthologies ever um you
know they made other ones too i think
they made the skull which was also with
peter cushing which i think we reviewed
but
you know they were uh going down the
tank at this point they didn't have a
lot of money i'm sure and you can kind
of tell from this uh movie
the werewolf is basically just a big dog
with
it looks like maybe they put kind of
like extra fur on it so it would look
like a big black wolf it doesn't look
terrible but they didn't really try to
but you can it's obviously a dog you
know what i mean so it's just kind of
like the werewolf is trying to like
attacking and everybody's just like
who's a good boy you know what i mean
it's like that kind of thing so it's it
kind of takes a little bit of the menace
out of it was like oh look how cute he
is so so it's that but like i said i'm
not gonna [ __ ] on too hard because you
know if you don't have the money to do
like a really good werewolf
it's probably better to just go the dog
routes because at least that's an actual
animal then try to like put some cheap
ass looking appliances on somebody
that's gonna look like ass so you know
so i'm not gonna [ __ ] on too hard for
that but the thing about it is that the
so the technology doesn't really end up
factoring into it all that much because
at one point because this takes place
over three nights
at one point the werewolf or the dog uh
crashes through this skylight and kills
the guy that's like monitoring all the
[ __ ] so at which point like the
technology is still kind of working but
they don't really have anybody to
collaborate with you know nobody's like
watching it so it kind of like all goes
to hell
another thing too is that you can kind
of tell
that because here's the thing you would
think that you were like okay one of
these six people or whatever is a
werewolf for sure you invite them all to
your house you know it's gonna be a full
moon it seems like to me the easiest
thing to do
would just be to like lock them all in a
room until the full moon comes and the
one that turns into a werewolf you know
you could even chain them to the walls
if you wanted to like just they wouldn't
hurt each other um you know what i mean
i mean if you're really that sure you
just lock them all in a room don't just
let them wander around loose which is
what he does i mean he essentially just
treats them like
dinner guests they try to do these
little things where and it's kind of
it's funny because it kind of reminded
me of the thing where they were like
putting the putting the blood in the
petri dishes and then putting the
you know putting the heat to it to see
whose blood would jump um it kind of
reminded me of that
but they have a thing cause peter
cushing says oh well you know silver is
poisonous to wolves they can't even
touch it um and they'll instantly die
which okay i've never you know i've
never really heard that i mean yeah
obviously silver but i thought it had to
be like i thought it had like they had
to ingest it or it had to like go into
their body i didn't think just like
touching it would kill them but okay
i'll allow it so
so he's like okay well they can't even
touch it so
so uh tom newcliffe is kind of like well
this candlestick right here silver so
we'll just pass it around the table
but various things so they do that and
nobody dies
and then peter cushing says oh yeah but
um also
wolfsbane pollen has to be in the air at
the same time which to me
that seemed like it needed some
workshopping you know what i mean
because it seemed like
you set up all these really easy like
werewolf tests and then there's always
like some reason why they didn't work i
was like i kind of feel like that could
have been
changed up some you know what i mean
because
yeah if the silver didn't kill anybody i
said oh well obviously uh peter cushing
doesn't know what he's talking about
then because the silver didn't kill
anybody but then it they added this
thing and i was just kind of like okay
really all right whatever but so there's
that
and then there's like reasons why
certain people won't touch and
everything like that so as it goes on um
you can tell that they're leaning really
hard into making you think that this one
particular person is the werewolf
which led me to believe that guy is
absolutely not the werewolf because they
really really want me to think that he
is so i'm just kind of like okay well
i'm trying i'm scratching them off the
list then because there's no way because
they're being like way too obvious about
it
now i will i don't know if i want to
spoil this or not i mean even though
it's very old uh it's from 1974. i don't
know i guess i can but because i guess
it's not i will say
this is not a great movie especially
like as far as like amicus and you know
their competitor hammer they made like
many many many better ones than this
um it's pr it's an okay werewolf movie
and i like
the idea
of
making essentially like an agatha
christie parlor mystery but with a
werewolf i think that's really cool
but i'm not sure how well it was
executed just because of like stuff like
i said i don't even mind that the
werewolf is just like a dog that doesn't
bother me like i said i would rather see
that than see like some cheap ass
latex appliances or just like an actor
run around with fur stuck on their face
i think you know it's at least it's a
dog it's a wolf it's close enough you
know what i mean it's an actual animal
and that's fine
but
i just didn't like how
kind of contrived the setup was
because as i mentioned it seemed like if
that was a situation that you were ever
in you know i mean not that you would be
but if you really were it's like oh one
of my friends is a werewolf it seems
like there would be much less
convoluted ways to discover that fact
rather than what we were shown you know
i mean so it kind of like strained
credulity a little bit where i was like
why don't you just lock them all in one
big room so they can't get out it's like
problem solved easy peasy first night
full moon somebody wolves out bang
they're dead you know what i mean but he
but he just lets them like wander around
the grounds by themselves even though
he's like hey where's so and so like
when something happens and then they
have to go find them
you know but then like i said the whole
test with the silver candlestick and
then they're saying oh no never mind
there has to be wolfsbane pollen and
then you know uh tom newcliff is like oh
well i happen to have some wolfsbane
growing in my greenhouse and it's like
whew now now i blew the the wolfsbane
pollen into the air now everybody
touched the silver thing and then
there's like reasons why they can't
touch the silver thing and it's just
like this whole thing so i kind of feel
like that could have probably been left
out or it could have been rewritten to
be like less convoluted because
again it just i was just kind of like
come on you guys i mean this seems like
it should be much easier than it is and
essentially the werewolf being just like
a dog and them like outsmarting
uh what is supposedly like one of the
world's greatest hunters again it didn't
come across as very believable now i'm
not saying that i didn't like this movie
because i did i thought it was kind of
fun uh it does drag somewhat and like i
said some of the stuff is just so
contrived that i couldn't really get
into it because i'm just like
really you know what i mean there was
that but i really kind of liked all the
campy overactive particularly uh calvin
lockhart i think was like kind of
he was very very like over the top and
theatrical and i kind of dug that um
also he wears a shirt at one point in
this which is one of the coolest shirts
i've ever seen it was like it looked
like i don't know if it was silk but it
looked like black silk but then it had
like this silver
like really really shiny like so not not
like um
not like sparkly necessarily but like
shiny metallic and it had like these
little uh this little trim around the
collar and then it had just like these
really really shiny kind of like two
stripe type situations or symbols or
something going down there it was really
really cool looking i just like really
liked the cut of it and just like the
black and silver was really nice i just
thought i would bring that up uh but
yeah so i really liked that uh peter
cushing was great and he's always great
in everything and it was cool to see
like i said michael gambon and some of
these other actors like charles gray and
stuff that you've seen in other stuff
but it's kind of like fun to speculate
that it's like maybe they're a werewolf
and [ __ ] also
uh this has
which maybe undercuts the horror a
little bit but i don't care because i
dug it especially during the beginning
when uh tom newcliffe is kind of testing
out his you know werewolf trap uh
technology kind of uh perimeter thing he
has going uh it has like the funkiest
like
wakachika 70s kind of like music and
it's just like so hilarious so it's like
if you like open if you didn't know this
was a werewolf movie the opening scene
with this kind of like disco like funky
you would probably think it was a black
exploitation and i kind of think that
they wanted to go with that direction
because like i said this was 1974 and
blaxploitation movies were kind of all
the rage
so i kind of think that they wanted to
do something
sort of like old school horror but with
a blaxploitation edge to it so i kind of
got that vibe because the first part of
it is very much like a black
exploitation movie with the music and
the way it's set up before you even know
it's like a horror it's kind of more
seems like an action movie at the first
uh the first part of it but then it goes
again like more into an old-fashioned
hammer style or old amicus style
you know parlor mystery like agatha
christie something like that where it's
just like a bunch of people in one
location one of them is a murderer in
this case a werewolf and you're trying
to like figure it out who it is did okay
so the big question i'm sure that you
all are asking or not i'll probably
probably not did jenny
guess who the werewolf was
that's not an easy question to answer
because
i sort of did
but they kind of throw you a curveball
though
i will say that as the movie goes on the
dude that they're very obviously setting
up is like oh that guy's got to be the
whirl if i'm like well then there then
he's obviously not that it's like a
giallo film where the person that
there's be like it's this person they're
so guilty and i'm just like it's not
that person just stop it we've we're on
to that we're on to that trick it's
never the most obvious person and so the
most obvious person in this i was like
okay well it's definitely not that
person
but then
they kind of do a thing after they do
the werewolf break they even have like
the narrator and everything like i said
the director was not a fan of this idea
he was like really do we need the
[ __ ] gimmick but the producer's like
yeah we absolutely do and i don't know
if it helped i mean
i think the movie did okay maybe but you
know after that uh you know amicus went
out of business so obviously even if it
did do okay it didn't do well enough to
save them
so there was that
i mean they it might have gone downhill
anyways i don't think the gimmick really
mattered one way or the other and
honestly i'd be interested to see it
without it but i do kind of like some of
those cheesy ass
like i said william castle type things
like the tingler and all that kind of
stuff like he used to do back in the old
days like in the 50s and 60s uh so i
kind of liked seeing that like in a more
70s sort of way i did kind of guess but
as i said
they throw you a curveball uh in the
sense that and this is a spoiler
um there's actually two werewolves but
one of them didn't become a werewolf
until later so if they are asking did
you guess who the original werewolf was
yes i did but
there's another one so there's that
but
you know what i mean so i kind of
guessed but
like i said they pulled uh oh we you
know we did something different with it
so it's not like as straightforward as
you might think which you know fair
enough because you don't want a big bill
i guess that's that was lame uh that was
that kind of thing but yeah so
is this worth watching yeah i mean it's
campy
it's very 70s um if you like murder
mysteries and you want to see kind of
like a little different take on it then
you might be into it if you like kind of
like that kind of gimmicky uh sort of
thing like i said werewolf break i think
this is the and they really really
pushed uh that gimmick in the marketing
as well so if you like that kind of
thing which i kind of do i think it's
kind of cute but uh you know so if you
want to see that then
then you should like uh check it out if
you like amicus's other stuff i think i
like this slightly better than the skull
but i don't know that's hard to say
because i kind of did like this goal as
well but amicus definitely
in their last few years their stuff
wasn't as good and especially their um
they're kind of like standalone films i
think were never
they never got to the same level as
their anthologies i mean anthologies
seemed like
that's what their big thing was and they
were really good at doing those um but
this is absolutely worth watching if
you're into kind of like low budget
werewolf movies stuff from the 70s it's
always worth watching for peter cushing
and like i said there's a lot of other
great actors in this as well um you know
so that if that sounds like it'd be
worth your time then absolutely watch it
i watched it on shutter uh you know but
i'm sure it's many other places as well
so if you've seen it let me know what
you thought about it in the comments and
that will do it for this episode of
flickers if you're on our monster march
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye